shortly after four o'clock this morning
i spoke to president zlensky of ukraine
to offer the continued support of the uk
because our worst fears have now come
true
and all our warnings have proved
tragically accurate
president putin of russia
has unleashed war in our european
continent
he's attacked a friendly country without
any provocation
and without any credible
excuse innumerable missiles and bombs
have been raining down on an entirely
innocent population
a vast invasion is underway by land
by sea
and by air
and this is not in the infamous phrase
some far away country of which we know
little
we have ukrainian friends in this
country neighbors co-workers
ukraine is a country that for decades
has enjoyed freedom and democracy
and the right to choose its own destiny
we
and the world
cannot allow that freedom just to be
snuffed out we cannot and will not
just look away
it's because we've been so alarmed in
recent months that
russian intimidation that the uk became
one of the first countries in europe to
send defensive weaponry to help the
ukrainians
other allies have now done the same and
we will do what more we can in the days
ahead
today in concert with our allies we will
agree a massive package of economic
sanctions designed in time to hobble the
russian economy
and to that end we must also
collectively cease the dependence on
russian oil and gas that for too long
has given putin his grip on western
politics
our mission
is clear
diplomatically politically economically
and eventually military this hideous and
barbaric venture of vladimir putin must
end
in failure
and so i say to the people of russia
whose president has just authorized a
tidal wave of violence against a fellow
slavic people
as the parents of russian soldiers who
will lose their lives
i cannot believe this is being done in
your name
or that you really want the pariah
status it will bring to the putin regime
i say to the ukrainians in this moment
of agony
we're with you we're praying for you and
your families and we are on your side
and if the months ahead are grim
and the flame of freedom burns low
i know
that it will blaze bright again in
ukraine because
for all his bombs and tanks
and missiles i don't believe that the
russian dictator will ever subdue the
national feeling of the ukrainians and
their passionate belief that their
country should be free
i say to the british people and all who
have heard the threats from putin
against those who stand with ukraine
we will of course
do everything
to keep our country safe
we're joined in our outrage by friends
and allies around the world
we will work with them for however long
it takes
to ensure that the sovereignty and
independence of ukraine is restored
because this act of wanton and reckless
aggression
is an attack not just on ukraine
it's an attack on democracy and freedom
in eastern europe
and around the world
this crisis
is about the right of a free sovereign
independent european people to choose
their own future
and that is a right
that the uk
will always defend